- Marie-Johanne Lessard souffre
de fibromyalgie depuis 12 ans.
MARIE-JOHANNE LESSARD
- Comme si on avait une carie
et qu'on mord sur un papier
d'aluminium. Ça fait des chocs
comme ça.
- Depuis quelque temps,
elle participe à un groupe
de gestion de la douleur avec
une panoplie de spécialistes.
- J'ai adhéré à des groupes
de douleurs chroniques qui m'ont
aidée incroyablement.
Moi, c'était à neuf, ma douleur,
et là, maintenant, on varie
entre zéro et un.
- Si le traitement contre
la douleur progresse,
c'est grâce entre autres
à deux chercheurs américains.
- David Julius
and Ardem Patapoutian.
- Récipiendaires du prix Nobel
de médecine cette année,
leurs découvertes ont permis
de comprendre comment
la température et le toucher
envoient des impulsions
nerveuses au cerveau.
YVES DE KONINCK, professeur,
Université Laval
- En fait, quand vous mettez
votre main sous l'eau chaude,
quand ça brûle, ça veut dire
que la température a dépassé
45 degrés. Et lui, il a
découvert le récepteur
qui signale ça.
- Professeur à l'Université
de Californie, David Julius
a utilisé la capsaïcine,
qu'on retrouve dans le piment,
pour identifier le capteur
de la peau qui réagit
à la chaleur.
Ardem Patapoutian, lui,
est professeur à l'Institut
de recherche de Scripps
en Californie. Il a découvert
les capteurs qui répondent
aux stimuli mécaniques.
- En ayant identifié
ce récepteur-là, il se trouve
à avoir ouvert la porte
à la découverte de tous les
récepteurs qui sont responsables
d'abord des sensations
douloureuses, mais aussi
du toucher.
- Les travaux des deux
physiologistes sont
particulièreent utiles dans
les recherches sur la douleur.
ANNE-MARIE PINARD,
CHUL de Québec, Université Laval
- Ça nous permet... pas
nécessairement pour l'instant
d'avoir de nouveaux médicaments,
mais peut-être d'utiliser mieux
et de façon plus spécifique
les armes qu'on a actuellement
pour traiter la douleur
chronique.
- Au Canada, une personne
sur cinq souffre de douleurs
choniques, comme Marie-Johanne,
qui garde espoir qu'un jour,
elle guérira complètement.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, M